October 4th is National Taco Day! Tacos
are small, cheap, and easy to assemble. And
they're delicious! They're the perfect
food to get from a food truck.
Who doesn't love a taco truck? Well,
restaurants and regulators, that's who. As
food trucks have exploded in popularity
over the past decade, they've encountered
regulatory roadblocks in dozens of
cities. Some regulations are sensible
rules about food safety, but some cities have
barred food trucks from parking or
consign them to hidden corners of the
city. Others have banned them outright!
These regulations have nothing to do
with protecting consumers, and everything
to do with crushing competition. In DC,
Chicago, El Paso, and elsewhere, the
restaurant lobby has fought to curb or
restrict food trucks. The lobbyists
sometimes admitted their
anti-competitive intentions, but often
they tossed out bogus arguments about
sidewalk safety or the like. This is a
hidden aspect of regulations — always
pushed in the name of protecting the
public, they often serve most to protect
special interests from competition.
Do you think food trucks have an unfair
advantage over restaurants? Let us know
in our poll. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and more
videos from a AEI.